desde el cielo una retahíla de
bombardeos con drones kamikazes golpeó
la capital ucraniana kiev en las calles
el rugido de las sirenas columnas de
humo y el rostro del miedo hace mucho
teníamos miedo porque sabemos que los
drones vuelan a menudo hacia los
apartamentos y las casas normales y yo
estaba segura de que volaría hacia
nosotros
el alcalde de la capital vitalliccod
calificó a Rusia de estado terrorista
tras los ataques en niko life los
bomberos tardaron más de 5 horas en
extinguir un incendio sobre unos tanques
de almacenamiento de aceite de girasol
el ministro de defensa ruso señaló que
los aviones del kremlin destruyeron seis
depósitos de municiones ucranianas en
varios lugares durante las últimas 24
horas las fuerzas armadas de la
federación rusa continuaron realizando
ataques con armas de alta precisión y
largo alcance tanto por aire como por
mar con base en los sitios de comando
militar Comunicaciones y energía de
Ucrania todos los objetivos han sido
alcanzados este lunes la planta nuclear
de saporiya también tuvo que ser
desconectada de la red eléctrica por las
afectaciones de los bombardeos ru se
trata de la central nuclear más grande
de Europa que pese a estar operada por
personal ucraniano es el kremlin quien
tiene el control
terroristas rusos bombardearon una vez
más subestaciones de infraestructura
critican el territorio controlado por
Ucrania lo que provocó el cierre de la
última línea de comunicaciones
znpp dinoprovska de 750 kilobytes a las
3:59
Moscú intenta contrarrestar semanas de
pérdidas en el campo de batalla con una
política punitiva de daños a las
instalaciones energéticas un golpe
estratégico de cara al invierno con
graves consecuencias para la población
civil a pesar de que Vladimir Putin
había dicho la semana pasada no haber
motivos para más ataques masivos contra
Ucrania